[Music]
dear girl oftentimes we women start to
rise and then certain people devise a
plan to disenfranchise whether it's our
bodies or rights entice us with
movements unite us through persecution
make it seem like it's all right dear
girl open your eyes
we have come so far it's easy to resign
we've got equality but public policy
shows the contrary honestly no surprise
since we perpetuate rape culture
separate locker room talk in that one
audiotape that's great
I get 78 cents to a man's dollar while
black and Latina women get even smaller
what should every girl know you are not
some puppet in a puppet show expose the
double standards the hypocrisy the hate
it is never too late this is the moment
of girls taking the reins it is times up
it is me too it is everyone from me to
you who has spoken or stayed silent but
strong it is
Emma Gonzalez and lean away from dodging
bullets and dodging hate Christine Blasi
Ford and every survivor that speaks only
to be met with intimidation
investigation and disbelief dear girl
you will be believed if not by Senate
floors and investigators we will hear
you dear girl we will see you dear girl
we will stand by you for the survivor
3,000 miles away or the one next door
you are heard justice will not always
prevail but we will continue to fight
tooth and nail you are heard so that our
sisters and daughters will never be
asked rather harassed whether they
wanted it regretted it or just forgot
believe me no one forgot dear everyone
this moment is a movement for every girl
to reclaim her place win every race for
everyone out there listen in the system
is in demolition grab a hold of your
voice it is time to make a choice to
believe survivors to pay us all the same
to give women of color equal access and
opportunity to protect the safety of
trans girls every day make the choice to
change the climate
make the choice to not stay silent this
is not just the day of the girl this is
the future of girls
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]